[Music]
the game of politics for many decades
has been played as one in which you're
supposed to keep your head down
you're supposed to be bland you're
supposed to be uncontroversial your job
is to court as many people as you can in
the middle Donald Trump from the very
beginning took a different posture
everything he did was about unleashing
the agency of a small number of intense
supporters this was going to be a
campaign in which you could unleash the
things that you'd been thinking maybe
your mad uncle muttering at the
television and suddenly every mad uncle
muttering in the television was
empowered was sent a signal by this man
that those private thoughts could now be
made public as Donald Trump's candidacy
unfolded he built and created a
symbiotic relationship with what we
think of as a vast decentralized social
media army that did his bidding during
the campaign these were mostly young
white men on platforms like Reddit and
4chan and they developed this kind of
culture of competing with each other
vying with each other to produce the
most creative the most sticky the most
intrusive meme or message that would
penetrate social media and then seep
into the mainstream media so everyday
they would do this and in response to
the events of the new cycle be it
Hillary Clinton's latest comments be at
Donald Trump's latest policy
pronouncements they would go take that
moment and elevate it the mainstream
media were generally confident that
Hillary would win the election she was
ahead in the polls fairly consistently
and because she had much higher
favorables while both candidates were
unpopular Hillary's favorables in public
opinion polls were generally about 10
points higher than Donald Trump's but
the people doing social media sentiment
analysis firms like foresee were
tracking and finding something very
different their job is to track net
sentiment on social media in connection
to political debates and what they were
finding throughout the campaign was that
while Donald Trump's favorables were
about 10 points lower than Hillary he
net favorability on social media was
about 10 points higher than Hillary one
of the most striking facts we discovered
when researching this book was that the
day that Donald Trump had the highest
net favorability on social media was his
darkest day of the campaign it was the
day of the Access Hollywood tape being
released and it was because at that day
his supporters who had such intensity of
commitment to him rallied around him
they surged to his defense and even
though it seemed in the mainstream media
like this was a day that was all losing
for Donald Trump on social media that
day Donald Trump actually won he was
elected because he intuitively
understood what we call new power and
new power is this ability to harness the
energy of a connected crowd and while
Hillary Clinton had a very traditional
relationship with her crowd Donald Trump
had a relationship that reflects what we
now know you need to do in order to
really build depth of commitment
politically so the NRA
understands intensity in the same way
that Donald Trump does one of its great
strengths is in addition to its old
power brand the fact that it's a feared
institution that politicians kind of
quiver at the thought of it also has an
incredibly powerful new power arm and
that arm goes beyond just its membership
it actually has been very effective at
cultivating the most extreme elements of
its support base if you listen to it NRA
ad now they actually don't really talk
about guns anymore they talk about this
conspiratorial worldview they pit
liberals against people with their
values they suggest that government is
on a mission to take away people's
liberties and what they've learned is
that the way to keep intensity in their
crowd the way therefore at moments that
really matter for it
like the manchin-toomey bill well you
remember when that bill came to Congress
after the Newtown massacre ninety
percent of Americans supported
background checks in public opinion
polls
yet the 10% of people who opposed them
what and the reason they did was at that
moment the NRA was able to rally the
intensity of its supporters to outnumber
for gun control forces 8 to 1 in calls
to the key senators who were the swing
votes on that issue and the way they've
done that is not by reining in their
supporters but actually unleashing their
agency by providing micro grants to
small highly extreme political
organizations at the grassroots level
all over the country by supporting the
commerce the culture the politics and
the totalizing worldview of gun rights
supporters and in doing so they've
actually been led by their extremes but
it's their extremes that are helping
them to keep the power that they have
the question that those of us who want a
world that's different to the world that
Donald Trump is building is how do we
stop him what will it take it won't be
another candidate who is marginally more
favorable or popular than Donald Trump
but lacks the intensity that capacity to
mobilize new power that Donald Trump
demonstrated it will need to be a
candidate it will need to be a movement
that has real intensity behind it you
know we think of those Parkland kids and
to me they're the hope because what
they're showing is they understand this
need to generate intensity they
understand how to use new power they've
got this intuitive understanding that
it's not enough just to be right it's
not enough just to strut up the facts
that you have to embody that message in
a way that means that if you're you're a
kid anywhere in the world you can take
that adapt it make it your own these
movements tend to be decentralized they
tend to not have strict messaging
associated with them and they tend to be
structured in such a way like the me2
movement where you can take a frame
adapt it and add your own points